[Music]
flight recorders are on t minus five
four
three
two
one
zero
we have left
[Applause]
there's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
begin
to infinity
and
[Music]
i wear what i want say what i want 24 7
365.
i know it's a lot
but i don't have time to mess
this is gonna be the best year ever
and nothing's gonna get in my way all
breakfast is ready
[Music]
is everything
okay i'm a gross red monster
[Applause]
oh look at me stay back this happened
already
what did you say
our ancestors had a mystical connection
with red pandas are you kidding me this
little quirk runs in our family
[Music]
you're so cute sick i've always wanted a
tail i'm a freak we love you mae you're
our girl
whoa you're you
any strong emotion
will release the panda abby hit me
[Music]
do you know how dangerous this is you'll
get whipped up into a frenzy and panda
all over
my whole life i've been perfect little
maymay
but maybe i like this new me
mama's girls
it's gonna be may
many years ago
this candle blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita came to life with
magic
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was given their own magical gifts
uh-huh uh-huh i understand you
i'm not super strong like luisa the
donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect isabella
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
let me help you
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
i have climbed
the highest mountains
have run
through the fields
only to be
with you
only to be with you
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
but i still
haven't found
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
dream big trees
we just gotta be brave now wrong again
again
you will never be great johnny
what i'm looking for
[Applause]
found
what i'm looking for
[Music]
wake up buddy it is one o'clock
maybe i should let him sleep
okay
[Music]
go for a walk
i have an owner and he's superman let me
just turn that out
i should call me iron man
no
my dog's the best but he's not the
greatest with other animals what is new
with you fellow normal dog i bit the
fedex guy the other day who is he
working for general zod the legion of
doom
fedex of course the federation of exes
not to be trusted
what is taking my owner so long
well well well
if it isn't the justice league
superman
what's going on
you're super strong i should be a lot
more dead right now right
my best friend is in danger and you have
to help me well we're just a bunch of
shelter pets
but they're stronger than you think the
mighty oil
i didn't see anything
on wheels
where the heck am i indestruct dog
when one has an abundance of power
they have a certain duty to use that
power to
sorry you were saying something
how much did you have to drink i had two
toilet bowls and a bidet bidet too just
which is crazy i didn't even know that
was a thing but it's like a dog water
fountain
oh out of the way cat child
hey deploy k92 what is a k-9
excellent shielding that seemed
incredibly painful
anybody want to switch powers
it's time for us to move out and make
our mark on the
world no
those ding-dongs went back to the lost
world oh and i thought i made bad
choices
the lost world
the world's most dangerous place
wait a minute can you repeat that
i had a marshmallow in my ear oh [ __ ]
crying out loud
what brings you to here
we came here to live a life of adventure
like
you starting to question our judgment
this is the perfect time to do it
it's time to get
[ __ ] wild [ __ ] you like a superhero
i wouldn't use the term superhero
[Music]
i mean i wouldn't stop you from using it
ah
i love family reunions
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
behold the transformation ray awesome
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up johnny oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
dad
you're human drag oh no i have a total
dad bod
um what is going on
what's up
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
we need to find a way to fix this
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed and the goal
right
still human
[Music]
huh
you're not a vampire the sun won't fry
you now it's glorious it's wondrous
it's burning my eyes
if we don't fix you guys dude you'll be
like this forever seriously everybody
relax
just enjoy the view ah please
being a human is the worst and swim
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun the only place to
experience transfer mania is in a cinema
welcome to the vicious
[Applause]
[Music]
hello
everybody here for the interview
me too
what do you drive
i got the jet bike they're ready to see
you mr crew oh good great
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
my name is cru
i feel like i'm talking too loud even
though our proximity doesn't require
this kind of volume
you seriously think a puny little child
can be a villain
yes i am pretty despicable you don't
want to cross me
come back when you've got something evil
to impress me
[Music]
i'll distract them
this is the biggest day of my life
this kid just stole something from the
world's villains in the world
time to strike now
[Music]
are you pulling on my legs right now
otto where's the stone oh vegas
pasta
[Music]
did you just trade my future
oh i didn't mean to scare you now
where's groom
are you ready
this is the main event
[Applause]
come get some of
[Applause]
this hey who wants a selfie
tentacular i've got your whole life
story tattooed on my body
yeah
in a long history of monster wrestling
there has never been a champion quite
like kentucky fans around the world are
asking is there a challenger out there
with the hunger
the drive
the discipline to become the next
champion
what all right i think that's enough for
today
steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him did
he eat one
thank you that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately i know just
the thing
what
yeah that's going to be a hard no for me
[Music]
oh boy oh this is my nightmare
[Music]
uncle casey can't just stay for one
night one night
[Music]
really
how big is he gonna get that depends on
how much you love him
clifford how did this happen
[Music]
that's a big red dog
you know i'm a little better why don't
you take his temperature where in the
animal temperature taking place
[Music]
it's all over the internet there's a 10
foot dog in upper manhattan that can't
be real we are offering a 25 000 reward
for the capture of the big red dog
people don't like things that are
different
there are no other dogs like you what's
he doing i think he's trying to be small
[Music]
what if you found someone who was so
full of love
he's sleeping
made me feel like you could do anything
your dog just saved my life
i'm getting clifford out of here you
know how to drive how hard can it be
i'm grounded for life aren't i you and
me both
he eats like an animal he's an animal
i'm talking about him
what
[Music]
every kid has that one gift they want
more than anything for christmas
this is the story of mine
bookends they have baseballs on them i
see that no not those nintendo
a maze of rubber wiring and electronic
intelligence so advanced it was deemed
not a video game but an 8-bit
entertainment system no nintendo on my
house i second that looks like a no-go
on nintendo
i needed a christmas miracle
the year was 1987 or was it 88 super
bowls okay does it really matter dad oh
okay the year was the late 80s i was 11
years old did you wear a helmet yeah we
always wore helmets in the 80s
me and my friends would do anything just
to play one any of you huddle masters on
a flight
what have you brought me
untraceable cash money
[Music]
one thing became clear i needed to get
my own this is bigger than christmas
[Music]
this is our vietnam i don't think that
means what you think it means i have no
idea what it means we're gonna get in so
much trouble
sometimes during christmas just when you
think that all hope is lost something
magical happens
[Music]
sold out in 20 minutes suddenly one
woman punched a grandma right in the
throat
same family too
are you making all this up no no no way
you guys here in the race selling
contests first prize is a brand new
nintendo entertainment system
i'm gonna kill you
hold on
there are no rules
that nintendo's mine
what do you want to buy a reef this kid
thinks your wreath sucks
video games
have been doing all kinds of strange
things to children
what it was the 80s stuff got real
red dog this is bluebird this is rainbow
one what happened to red dog i changed
it well let's change names now this is
millennium falcon super cool
[Music]
[Music]
where have you been oh you were supposed
to be here working i lost track of time
this is the real world sometimes you
just gotta let your dreams go
i just scribble in my notebook i'm a
stock boy that's it you are a legit
designer
let me add them
dude i love it
[Music]
i want to lick them
i'm kira oh hold up
kira king aka sneaker royalty
boom the king's charity yeah design some
sick kicks show off your talent at the
most exclusive sneaker event of the year
that could happen this is your shot
come on get up
you've got sneakers to make
[Music]
it's you did you design these yeah
you're the guy
that everybody's been talking about
tonight this is destiny
i'm going for my goals
than my kids
[Music]
first of all this is a journal not a
diary tomorrow is the first day of
middle school luckily i'm not alone in
this middle school thing i've got my
best friend rally
here's what you need to know watch where
you sit on the first day of school don't
use the bathroom on the second floor and
finally don't
get the cheese touch
because if you do you might as well be
dead
thank you roderick for that wonderful
pep talk
we're out of our league here maybe my
mom can homeschool me
hey greg wanna come over and
play play play
[Music]
yep i'm pretty sure i'm gonna be in
therapy over this
we're in middle school now don't you
think it's time distracting our age
frankly wanna see my
secret freckle i'm like permanently
scarred from that night
look at these little nerds i'll pass
their bedtime
[Music]
disgusting
[Music]
but for now stuck in middle school
surrounded by morons
if you just stick with me everything
will be fine
[Music]
oh sorry i i thought you were teenagers
are you all right
you're all right
[Music]
good times or bad times we always look
after each other that's right because
we're all family lots of fellas out
there they want to be cowboys
i own everything except for this betty
benson's place find the deed to the
ranch and destroy it you'll have to sell
to me
uncle jerry we need reinforcements
[Music]
we've got predators threatening from all
over the west
i think we just got our plan
[Music]
we got a new sheriff
[Music]
[Music]
tom and jerry cowboy
[Music]
look for it on digital and dvd
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
when a young marmoset dreaming of
exploring the world
going around the world come on i don't
think so
meets a daring adventurer
you'll have time with a trick up his
sleeve
i will gladly bet you it's so gross that
i can go around the world in 80 days get
ready for an expedition bring my baby
home that's sure to be a blast
this summer
join phillies and pass part two
selfie time smile
and embark on an extraordinary journey
we're gonna shatter that record together
around the world
who are you we're here to rescue you
good work back there team follow me
frogs can't fly frogs who build planes
can
it was supposed to be the time of my
life hey i didn't do anything wrong
freeze frog you're under arrest
[Music]
you ate the mask what kind of world
class explorer hates the map he isn't so
bad
we make a good team
[Music]
around the world in 80 days quicksand
the last thing we should do is
coming
[Music]
this is a soon song full of danger
everywhere but don't you wear it all
that alfonso's own the giants that's not
a problem for this boy he will find a
way to beat him
his way to see the world makes him feel
sometimes alone but what nobody knows
he's got to say them all buddies they
are his painful friends that will always
keep him happy and safe
[Music]
this is
georgia girls aren't allowed to be
firemen but i'm as brave as any boy it's
my dream it's my destiny
girls can't be firemen give me a break
[Music]
extra extra arsonist strikes again
go into the theaters
they don't come out
i need you to run the fire investigation
i'll need a team here's the plan i
joined dad's team egg crate for the
stomach muscles mango for the biceps
and for the mustache
[Music]
oh okay too much
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
fastest cabbie in manhattan
who are you me uh i'm joe i'm fireman
joe slow down joe did you even check
this one
water pressure
we're going in
seriously
it's funny
you remind me of my daughter huh really
yeah that is funny
yeah she wanted to be a fireman too
so why didn't you teach her what you're
teaching me she's my daughter i love her
and i worry about her every second of my
life
[Music]
i catch the arsonist'll have to change
the rules then i'll be the first fireman
woman the job is far too dangerous
maybe this is a sign that it's time you
follow your own dreams
i never gave up on mine
[Music]
the mustache is very convincing it's my
dog's blood hair oh
looking forward to this all day come on
let's go
go where my new hiding place
[Music]
hey hold on just over here
[Music]
oh my gosh
what is this they're just like us
they walk up right and they're heavy
they
are what we used to be
mostly the uprights could be out here
somewhere if you don't take a chance now
this is war for you he's attracted
hello are you upright we didn't think
there were any orphans left this is
amazing
it was because of men that our ancestors
fled or stayed behind and we changed no
hands look at this
you distract me
look at me the distraction what are you
doing
oh boy
all right come to rescue us
we stand with you mostly
there's something noble inside of you
mostly
[Music]
something worth fighting for
[Music]
oh
[Music]
you